le coeur du débat dans la poitrine un
orbe aliose yann va enfin retrouver ses
parents après trois longues années
d'attenté
elle ne trouve même plus les mots il ne
pense qu'à serrer ses parents près forme
freedom unite réponse une date qui links
être au canada c'est la liberté dit ou 7
balyo diane fini les armes et les
massacres pour sa fille
ces retrouvailles sont le bon cadeau de
noël de toute sa vie
90 des réfugiés syriens arrivés sur le
premier vol nolisé par le gouvernement
était parrainé grâce à l'église
arménienne de toronto une prière
spéciale de bienvenue les attendait un
moment que nanard balyo ziane souhaite
immortaliser
mais il paraît voulons rose petite
séance d'orientation mardi rosmah
l'icann va ensuite allé retrouver celle
qu'il apparaît nue il a hâte d'entamer
sa vie au canada une vie normale mais
pour commencer il a hâte de dormir il
n'a pratiquement pas fermé l'oeil de la
nuit
c'est toute la communauté arménienne de
toronto qui se serrent les coudes pour
aider les nouveaux arrivants
donc on pourrait les aider entendre
d'eux pour leur trouver des logements du
travail pour 12 enfants avoué avoir
besoin d'être de transport disons pour
aller
leurs commentaires un petit qui tousse
new business ou ou ceballos diane lui ne
perd pas atteint il songe déjà à
démarrer sa propre entreprise dans la
prochaine année
mais d'ici là il y attend de proches à
retrouver et tant d'histoires à raconter
il a déjà l'air chez lui au canada ici
philippe leblanc radio-canada ton